so welcome on the second book has to be
my day thank you so much to finish so
that we discussed yesterday and into the
time because I better have a control i
make some slides it works so if you look
at yesterday's we had this promise
problem any games i had a parameter
epsilon and so you remember given a
bunch of equation bobbing two variables
modulo module okay and we wanted to find
an assignment to the variables that
satisfies as many of the constraints as
possible and we were promised that there
exists an assignment satisfies about my
epsilon fraction of the constraints and
the brooch for finding such an
assignment was to consider a serial
distribution that it models this you
know this abuse a probability
distribution over over these assignments
that satisfy 1 minus epsilon fraction of
the constraints and it is just the you
know everything that you need to know
about the definition of a seal disabuse
oh it's a function defined a reveller
function defined on on assignments to
the variables and it we have we have
this notation a corresponding to the
expectation of some arbitrary function
with respect to the tenses then its
density p and then we enforce some
conditions you know that its potential
pseudo expectations of squares on a
negative soon expectation of 1 is equal
to 1 and this condition which
corresponds to saying that you satisfied
1 minus epsilon fraction of the
constraints if you would do this for 40
minutes after degree D that would just
mean that probability solution over
assignments satisfiable myself some
fraction of the constraints and now we
relax this and only look only enforce
these consistency conditions up to
for somebody and that means that we can
also you know represent the sensitive
just by its low degree part without loss
of generality and that allows us to
compute these things efficiently but
just I mean the fact that capital these
low degree is not can be assumed no
decrease not part of the definition of
disability that you have to worry about
ever and so on one property that falls
out of this condition is that if your
condition the distribution deprime a
little special dear and get a new set of
distribution in prime in the group and
it's looking away such that T prime so
we saw the condition conditioning some
events preserves the condition that he
primed to distribution and this
condition here implies that even if you
condition on any any kind of event the
resulting civil distribution a prime
with still behave like it satisfies the
one my stepson fraction of the
constraints actually has a look at it
second still on average what am I never
fixed int yeah yeah so here we averaged
over the equations in the instance
exactly and this is equal to one myself
okay so that's a set out now we saw that
by conditioning on you know events
carefully on a few events carefully we
can make we can get a situation where
the the variables are uncorrelated on
average with each others if you pick two
in these two indices uniform random
variables then and you look at the
mutual information between xixj it's
very small roughly 1 over R when we
allow so the decree to drop by our okay
and the question was how how can we
exploit this and
the reason why for indie games you can
hope that this sort of as an interesting
effect is because if you look at this
kind of condition you know that x is
equal is minus XJ is equal to C with
high probability with probably close to
1 then this means that either XIO x-ray
are fixed to a particular value you know
the tape is to satisfy you know a fixed
is probably what 1 minus epsilon to a
particular value that satisfies the
equation or the distribution of xixj has
to be very correlated it almost
perfectly correlated it turns out in
here you have to use of the right
measures for correlation if you want to
you want to deal with this stuff in game
at the right priority but that's of
something that you can do so to hurt now
now we see that there are some tension
between having small global correlation
and this global correlation refers to
maybe pick two indices at random but but
at the same time if we pick two in two
indices that participate in a constraint
then the correlation is high so this is
you know the local correlation the local
correlation is high the global
correlation is small and so we ask you
know what what does it it can be does it
say something interesting about about
the instance if we have this kind of
discrepancy and what turns out and it
turns out to be the case so what would
you get directly it's a surprising
probability distribution over real
numbers on on the only constraint graph
which is the graph formed by connecting
indices inj the variables X I XJ
participate in an equation of the
instance okay what what a suit what does
mean to have this surprising so what I
mean by surprising
participation so it's a probability
distribution over RN so you know the
real number for every for every vertex
in the graph and it has a property that
if you look at a random edge then the
random variables are very concept are
very correlated in this sense and if you
look at two random indices to random
vertices then the the correlation
between the random variables IIM saij is
very small okay so we have craft that
that supports such such a probability
distribution and the question is what
does it mean about the graph and social
services yes is it because there's a
unique games ah yes so the so why is why
is it lame true that's a question or
because there's nasty piece yeah I mean
is I'd requires a proof it's a yes so
this this time i will type it i will
explain the proof on the next slide it's
a it's a it's almost non trivial and of
its it's not very in the following sense
so here you know we talk about a
particular kind of correlation you know
maybe the kind of correlation that says
that you know these variables they
satisfy any equation with high
probability and here we talk about
another kind of correlation that you
have to reevaluate random variables that
are correlated with each other in your
opinion the best way that you can poke
than to be correlated right so so this
means that this is this ratio I mean
this year can never be larger than this
quantity so this being one myself so on
is our best is larger almost as hot as
it can be the world over
global correlation you need to do some
work to move it from you till
information yes the other chefs and then
that necessary solution need to do some
more from there yes remote thing is some
of rating this notion of correlation and
this notion of correlation you paternal
like a pure eddie's distant these two
notions of relation of it incomparable
and now you want to unify them into one
into this facility for G so yeah but
what you're doing here is translating
between correlations and so the reason
why we can do that is precisely because
you know the because the fsvp solution
or because you know another way of
saying it because the pseudo
distribution satisfies the condition if
today I said it before this in the SDP
setup should I think of this beta is
some kind of Gaussian projection average
of conservatives exactly it is
in the web address may even be silly
there's actually a somewhat intuitive
interpretation of these standard vectors
in terms of students in case why why is
this what does this mean this I'm
telling that this means something about
the ground and what it means about the
craft is that first it means that the
random walk on the graph mix is very
slowly in the following sense even if
you would do this number of random steps
in the graph you see only a very small
fraction of of the other vertices the
dissolution will be we know will not be
uniform policies that you would expect
after you know lots of said we would
expect that the execution is uniform
over all vertices but this condition
implies that even after after this
number of random step European folk from
the phone from from particular vertex
your disabuse is concentrated on roughly
into the minus beta fraction of the
vertices so this property about running
boats in the graph now you know question
is what you know what what's the
combinatorial reason why the you know
can can be derived combinatorial
consequence from this slow mixing time
and indeed that's the case and what but
what it means is that if you take this
much time to to mix then actually the
reason has to be the exists are set that
is very small and its expansion is very
small and the reason why whether it's
the case so may be easiest to see in the
contrapositive so you know if if this
would be not true so meaning every small
sect has lots of people as large
expansion then you know that's all gives
you a way to just check that actually
the random walk mix of speaking because
in every step in sort of intergroup me
know what you see in you know if the
expansion would be larger than this
number you see let's say an epsilon over
beta fraction of new vertices and that
means that after our this number of
steps you sort of see everything typical
its beta beta yes yes so submit has
introduced here so this is a same camera
yeah is the gamma is from the from the
local correlation and so if you choose
come out to be if gamma choose it was
made us really satisfies this it's just
a week from addressing this little bit
so that you don't have box too many
locks appear is for this follows the is
it you if you have a short way and the
market the 20 pairs and their products
must be high yes yes so that's the
question so so why why why does this
condition imply that the random walk
mixes slowly and that's exactly what we
said what you said so what you can you
can show is that it's the following
if you sides at slightest these
conditions and now you pick you know not
just one right hand set but T random
steps then the correlation between the
eight points of the random walk is at
least 1 minus you know whatever it was
before the creation was before to raise
to the team
and so that means that yeah us know let
us know this is strange number come from
so that's an upper you know they give me
to salute okay let me pick up a little
bit so I want to say that the random
walk makes is slowly online so you just
want to compare this one may assess your
ability to come here comes together so
now I look at you know what what what
the what's the what's the correlation
that I have left after better / of
sometimes log n steps and then this year
if you choose this this agra st this
year will be much larger than n to the
minus beta which which means it
or it really much softer than in this
number and that means that you know that
your animal has a mix because you know
that people could use a thick two
vertices according to the stationary
distribution the correlation is very
small but if it but but what did when we
picked here if two vertices accor it was
runnable and the she said Brennan walk
and the correlation was very enough
there was much larger than it is for the
stationary mentioned and it means that
you
now what's the proof of the claim so it
is a little bit technical just give you
some high-level idea so it turns out
that like what's useful since we want to
construct now some of these these random
variables on the ground and what start
up whatever after that we useful is to
consider the following new Siri
description which is just the product of
our attended product of our given to
deceive me you know this is actually a
completely valid operation for
distribution so this even will now be
used to dissolution and instead of being
you know distributed over puts you know
Quinn solution safe is it disappear over
pairs of food solutions and because it's
a product you know sort of its
independent and you know it satisfies
all the conditions that we want from
cederstrom soon lucid dreams now now we
can define a faction on this you know on
the safeSpace liquid function that it
satisfies exactly the kind of properties
that we want in the foreign sensor if if
this condition is satisfied if X on
x-ray are related linear related with
probably the Prophet closer one then the
correlation between afif J under the 0
distribution is exposed to over 1 and
similarly if the variables xixj are
uncorrelated in the you know
you should mention sense then the soup
and the correlation of fif j on the
students abuse is is there a small okay
and so if you have such a fact as such a
factor in such functions f I then you
know you so for the same reason as Nene
can just sample a Gaussian random
variables are the same covariance its a
href Jerry and because you know it's a
solution like the covariance of this is
a 17-10 so you can actually sample such
reduction that would be exactly the
Excite would be any you know any other n
myrtle that has the same second moment
says if I and it exists just because we
have these these square we're not point
of the conditions or because it's an stp
but but notice there's a hole like this
means faction you can be a little bit
complicated so it's not yeah the
relationship of FI to the vectors
expressing it in terms of Pegasus is
somewhat surprising but sadhus Torres
look out as if I should look like look
at here so it turns out that essentially
the following function works the
following functions are what you so the
function f I given suit to assignments X
and X prime will be either equal to
minus 1 over K or equal to 1 minus 1
over K and language but look at this
weather the values for X I are the same
both X and X prime if you check whether
X and X prime is X I is equal to x pics
are prime that's the case in your foot 1
minus 1 over K
otherwise you're put just might work
okay and there's a side catch and this
stuff makes everything a little bit ugly
so this is precise Joyce only works if X
I has his full entropy in the solution p
prime which is a little bit cheating
because like nobody hope we obtain d
prime by conditioning and that tends to
D tends to reduce the entropy budget
it's like cheating in the sense that I
can hear them make if you choose if I'm
walk more carefully in the in the
general but but that contains I may not
here so so why does this make sense it's
actually like I know you can you can
really it's a bit you know if you look
at the scope for a trophy case you can
convince yourself that it satisfies
these conditions so you know so one
property the sense is that the
expectation is if you choose X and X
prime the airplane is that the
expectation of F I is equal to zero
under the seville solution the reason is
that you know if this has potential p
then the event X is equal to X I prime
happens with probability 1 over K so it
means that in the expectation you know
this part of you is one ok and this
going to use minus 1 over K so
expectation of fi 0 and that means that
if you know xixj are really you know if
this mutual information is close to 0
which means that xixj are close to the
pairwise independent then it means that
you know this this expectation is close
to the product of the expectations no
expectation of F I have sex became erect
right and that's that's a zero this is
ok now why is this why is this true and
this is true because you know if
if excise equal if xixj set-asides
innovation that got probably close to
one then you know basically if X xixi
prime tonight then also x-ray in x ray
Pratt polite gizem so those two events
are perfectly correlated and that that
means that this in qualities that's the
sketch of the proof of the claim now let
me give you a high level view of the
whole elaborate them so today whole
algorithms will be meeting you know we
get any games instance and set of
equations and if you compute the serial
execution now how do you how do you get
an assignment and what if you put in the
sign he is the overview of the algorithm
so there are three steps trying current
here to the steps and you repeat the
steps in 0 as long as possible so the
first thing is that so you get the
connected components of the constraint
run and if one of these components has
vocal cord as large global correlation
measured in terms of it just before the
component then you condition on event in
the component and reduce the edge of the
average entropy of the variables in that
component by quite a significant amount
now is that if all the components and
local club accreditation you can look if
in any of the components you know is it
true that most of the variables are
almost fixed so then we can just beat
off a good solution for for that
component and you know we choose that
assignment in and you know it satisfy
most of the equations ax most of the
equations net proponent and so that's
good and you can
continue now if all components will have
to look at low global correlation and
the inner piece of the variables is
large then we saw I said it has to be
the case that you know the random box on
this component it mixes goalie and that
means that we can cut out a set of the
component that you know who's Who sizes
n to the better fraction smaller than
the plasma component and the expansion
is small let's the algorithm now what is
analysis so this would be weekend and
you can think of this as he recursion
depth this maybe not to the right note
here but we can associate some depth in
the process and in the sense that you
know when we cut out I said you know
think of it as that new said that small
set here with me will be we think of it
as a depth being one smaller soon so
this is my component will be great here
you know define its it steps to be 1
plus the depth of the previous component
how do you identify it ah lets you know
if the render Bob makes is slowly then
it also means that you can you fish
define these sets that they don't extend
so you just you know to do the computer
distribution of the random book after
some concepts and then you know there
has to be sort of 11 times their prayer
you know this great ocean is this dustin
is very small and that method means that
you can set it is a small expansion
and guess I mean isn't this a nice
picture that you can draw this this this
is this component that you're looking at
here now you know you pick some vertex
you know that the random walk makes is
slowly so it means that you know if you
take one step you may be distributed
here once another seven distributed here
now even after login steps you know
you're still distributed around the very
very small part of the component is I
needs that you know one of these the big
eight steps the expansion was very small
you can compute these intermediate steps
this first thing like if they have solo
Croatia greater than this that that's
where you use this calcium or you're
saying from um where is it that you're
sampling is it simply since I'm since
the sampling is really only to prove
that the random walk mix and slowly so
you don't have to actually sample
so yes it's it so if you boys what do
these steps fail then you know that
mobile correlation is small and the
global correlation is large and then the
exists is this this distribution of real
numbers and that certifies that the
random walk mix is floating this is to
prove that there yes yes ok so it means
that in fact the number of times because
ever be years will create a new
component sizes n to the better fraction
smaller than the previous component it
means that we can you know the enough of
it number of times you can sort of go to
smaller components is the most one of
our beta so it means that we can sort
arrange the computation into into a tree
of death 1 over beta and it turns out
that in because the only cut things that
have expansion most have something
better in each in each level of the tree
the amount of number of total fracture
on edges to be deleting is it most as
much and that's a number of letters it
be enough so that's so this year it
tells us what's the total fraction of
edges that we are removing from the from
the from the constraint graph and you
know these edges they correspond to the
equations in another satisfied so the
PFDs of giving up on those equations and
the rest of the equations we are
satisfying
most of them to a satisfyingly step so
as long as this number here is smallish
we are in good shape and so it means
that if you choose example smallish if
it feels better to be roughly episode to
the one-third so natural in there and in
that means that okay what does it means
it means that for this Cobra correlation
we know that sort of the bond we can all
right and this this pound here the this
Alicia was so the bottleneck here is it
is this he has to be comparable to the
degree of the Civil expectation because
if you want correlation to be a public
relation to be this more the in theatre
condition n to the if I'm able two
additional into the better times roughly
and so it means the degree of the pseudo
resolution should be at least sent to
the interval into the better and so that
means the total running time of this
algorithm is you know 2 to the N to the
epsilon to the hotel
exponentially in the in the degree of
that resolution so I still don't
understand what is the exact claim that
you're making about being able to
identifying these small cuts
so I guess something like this you
obviously don't find it there yes so I
find something else yeah what you find
is so look at these okay so this we
establish that the random walk makes it
slowly now we have these these
distributions and the beta distribution
look like is energy so it is added some
products I then may the distribution
looks like after T steps is like this
and now what you get is that this here
you can think of it as I said that's the
collision probability of this is this
year and this you know sorry goes
related to baby there's the size of the
support of the other distribution and so
it means that it's a team rebound right
yeah yeah it's yeah okay I mean it's a
question yourself maybe maybe to what I
mean what function do you want to apply
the coupon and what you get from from
this condition at the random walk person
makes that quickly is that they exist
some tea in such that these two numbers
are most sorry down this year this we
expect this decrease is always here will
be at least 1 minus epsilon divided by
beta ok now what does this mean so now
if you rearrange this you know you can
think of if you look at the function now
e to the t minus 1 times okay this
recession returning this one should it
be a function where the letter that you
can apply the chica bomb yeah okay so so
you're not really finding
you're just this is an upper bound
expansion this is what you're really
finding is a separate small I can go ah
it's tricky to think about it in terms
of eigenvalues because you're a mean
what's really important is that the
reason what progress is from talking
about Ivy values in the way you usually
forgot in the body of serious inequality
is because we want a small thing yeah
and in the reason why why you get a
small setting this it is a look at this
function is because you know this
function will also will have a large
collision probability relatively large
relation problem so it means it is
function you know as I said corresponds
to a small set costs as well maybe this
picture here is so with this really like
the sets where the distribution is
concentrated after the different number
of steps in the random walk and you know
all these my Polly sets are small that's
what province and you know there are
many steps that you can do and that
means that one step has to be very sad
very small time is here
that was a thing this end the minus 2
beta is hopeless yes okay so that's
exactly what I wanted to discuss the
next so what's the yeah so what's maybe
a baby in modern aggressors who helped
you I mean what virus is not really why
could you not do something similar and
review the immigrants trajectory and yes
since you said like the why do we need
this very small the global correlation
and what do we do we actually need is
and some sense you know we need need
very very local correlation so it's an
example is it show that you can have
very low global coordination that's
still bad but that no-good partitioning
exists at all okay so it's not just
about you know the algorithm that you
use to fight the partitioning but the
examples that show that you know where
you can a very very low global
coordination and you know just it's just
not possible to partition the ground in
the desert somebody to get instructions
they sold locally testable boats
somewhat surprising connection and in
these examples I actually not just not
just bullying our this particular
they're not just saying something about
this particular approach so that's out
that basically the same examples and
they also show that if you only look at
Maloney are moments in the suit
resolution then you have to then you
need to invest super console decree
which means that you cannot work for 40
min time 11 and adhere you know this
look here comes with the
you know some some restriction so what
they quoted in the second show I said
they exists a civil distribution who you
know that in terms of the malawian
moments is very close to satisfying all
the constraints if you want to satisfy
it then you want to do the solution to
satisfy and so it means that you know if
the menu look at these monomial moments
is you know unless you are really
exploiting that things are look exactly
like Lee supposed to look like which is
sort of an acute infinite products of
approximation algorithms then yeah their
construction shows is that you need to
have super fun sandy green yes exactly
but you know if you do a linear
combinations then you know things that
look okay in terms of monomial moments
they might look very far off it terms of
after you take the linear combination
because you know the new combination it
might accumulate arrows so basically
they are these monomial moments they all
came up to some arrows but but they
still satisfy that squares are
non-negative for example so it's really
like squares are finally answered my
little spares of arbitrary point unless
they are non-negative but now it is a
look at you want to satisfy the
constraints and that's sort of a era
where there is some may be only it
thinks the don't hold exactly but all
you have to sometimes and so this that's
about what motivates okay and and now
okay so you might think that okay maybe
this means that you know so maybe it's
not a problem with these Mon Ami moans
name is just a problem with the whole
approach but it shuts out that if you
look at the serious tribution if you
look at these things in the right you
look at these moments in the right
places is it sadly no you know just the
basics change if you go to other other
moments but it doesn't if you look at it
in the right places then there's a very
easy argument a very robust argument
that shows that you know that these
instances these examples are not a
problem and the right basis turns out to
be
you know the light basis of an
appropriate operation and this is what
what motivated this way of thinking
about Mississippi solutions in a basis
in a kind of way and with it which is
what what we did with the individual
which is other is the goal of any sir
dissolutions in the series usual
viewpoints that for these things okay
this is it obvious squares and one
negative I mean the gear has degree
writers yes but for example when you
compute the expectation of Apple uncle
nah me and you exquisite you will sort
of want to replace these movements
consistently over you like so when you
think of when you get interested that
you want to think of the product of snd
all right yes I guess products but there
you will get Harrell's the muncie try to
substitute the inner products of the sdp
vectors into this polynomial you will
have to substitute each term within head
yes ok so maybe you maybe want it yeah
maybe only to say that it said like the
comet rivet e-commerce activity
properties are not are not none of the
satisfied as you would expect then you
know the positivity was I mean it
depends what what if what you mean by my
space that you never saw anything like
this so yes I mean it so this is having
this is not very no
this is more a question of taste you
know I mean but it means that it really
means that if you look at monomial
moments that you have to be very careful
with the you know if you want to avoid
this this is obstacle but and then the
fact that sort of it becomes very easy
in the right places is maybe I so much
motivation to look at infinity base
independently so now I wanted to do this
I wanted to talk a little bit for more
recent developments in the public's of
some squares also their higher level is
not as technically it's what we did the
snow and the following problem that they
wanted to talk about that's its you want
to find your spouse vectors in a
subspace so what would you set up is you
have any dimensional subspace you of RN
and you're given it in some 90 by some
faces vectors in aventura arbitrary
pieces and the process is that the
subspace contains a very sparse vector
and in your goal is to find such such
such as phosphate in subspace it is
actually you know quite quite possibly
related to to the national director and
the problems without problem we talked
about before so it turns out that this
problem is at least as hard as it's a
problem power is mostly expansion and
it's in the correspondence is most
clearly in the indicates wind when the
sparsity of the vector that we are
talking about is comparable to two
normal coordinates of the vector and
basically it's mostly expansions a
problem that you need to be you need to
solve if you're going to review the
negative in lecture and so it's a point
only time I've written four slots
expansion would be or even the opposite
point on the time I've written with the
major step towards tribute in reading
and conviction and so that the what's
our motivation for looking at this
problem but turns out that actually the
average case version is is has also been
spin side of this problem and it sits
and here it turns out that we can say
something you can say something new and
so the average Facebook version of this
problem is that you generate the
subspace in the following way you pick d
minus one random vectors say random
motion vectors and one which can achieve
an arbitrary phase perfection and you
look at the subspace spanned by all
these vectors and you're given it some
arbitrary basis maybe iranian faces I
know you to find this this perspective
so they're in something you maybe plant
11 spy recyclers none t minus one right
and vectors in this problem one way to
think about is it is of some some bed
some kind of edge broad problem for for
various and supervised learning house so
for example one previous work this from
Casali destroyed a steam and waiting
fright and the day motivation was to
solve the problem for dictionary
learning which is very basic as a pastor
and
yeah and what would the oh but it turns
out that at least the problems that have
been suggested by human man right hand
side little for my demented and
afterwards they have a limitation namely
the only book for various parts vectors
he saw this paucity of the vector has to
be small compared in only if the
dimension of the of this space is large
and which is actually which takes me
sort of not something that you wanted in
the context of smarts expansion because
you really wanted because it are sparse
just compared to the number of
coordinates and the algorithm is
proposing is actually very very simple
very nice you look at the subspace and
you find in the subspace the vector that
maximizes this ratio has the largest
infinity norm compared to the 11 and
this is something that you can do
exactly using a linear programming the
reason is that you know you guess which
of the end coordinates of this vector
this is the maximum and then you
minimize the 11 over the subspace with
respect to the constraint that your
large in the back has launched in that
particular port so there's a radio a
somewhat non-trivial through this kind
of this kind of very popular l1
minimization thing going on over some I
find some space and the effects of
wizardly you look at this is determined
body by your guests for anything
and by other it turns out that if you
use degree for dissolutions then you can
you can solve this problem in for larger
range of parameters in particular you
can solve it landed in the food's
positive range up to you know various
passages up to a concentration of the
coordinates as long as the dimension of
the subspace is not to do here what if
you know if it was me to be I would end
then here you need you know this this
this thing has to be you know still
sales significantly it was much much
faster than any constant cancer and they
don't have no I switching to the border
so if you don't have to promise art if
you mean Eddie Cutler yeah decided the
don't find leg which is the side of
subspace yes yes yes in this hard since
I mean I'm just I'm a trip so even a
proxy I was actually in approximating
this energy in general he may actually
the kind of approximation you want to
come off expansion you know that the
deities was a point on the time to do so
so there's a chance this is probably the
promise it's you know it probably
doesn't have as our opponent am i
Griffin but you know but for the
funniest for any in protection even a
quasi point of enzyme algorithm would be
very in over to refute connection so if
you relax this course just very are now
yes yes that sergeants implicitly always
have a grain structure oh I stick and if
yet it is still hard in this sense and
also in hospital in the direction so
this is how would you Albert you are
going to use udah solutions to solve
this problem so so in some sense the the
right thing that you would want to do is
you would want to find a vector in the
subspace that maximizes the s54 sea
lions take it with the larger yes
so that's the right optimization problem
that you would want to solve some sense
would be to maximize the too long
compared to the one we want to find the
vectors it has it has starch too long
compared to its one on you know instead
of instead of just finding a regulated
option feel it you know okay to Islam
because those a basically if this
condition is violated then if you do
this if you do this and everybody I know
you make a director is completely
unrelated to this car sector that you
wanted to find but if you have this
condition then they would succeed in
essentially in full range of progress
and since its what what would be natural
thing to do for this so you would want
to do distribution and it would now be a
function on the uniform of the subspace
you really value function of the units
on the uniform to subspace you reload
attraction what it means that now we
have to actually we don't have to think
about indifference because the people
because these things are all you know
you always represent these things as
point onions and then you know
integrating polynomials of the skills I
think that I know that and
and then you know yet this is the usual
conditions you know that square should
be non-negative and now is I want to say
that you know that the one norm is small
and adheres at some point where you run
into trouble because you know if you
look at the one arm it actually maybe
you say this a bit so what you would
what would you expect the one ought to
be of a case of our sector as a sparse
unit vector you really expect you know k
coordinates of value roughly 1 over K so
you would expect this one off to be in
ok times 1 over root K really expected
he's also now you would we want to add
the equation that you know the one or
should be in a fruitcake but now the
issue is that you know the one on here
is not a polynomial
in the you know the sense of functions
on on this board and this makes things
very complicated to to reason about now
one want me to resolve this because
actually which has been suggested in the
paper by one sparse so you're using the
linear programming on what sports
principal focus past principal component
analysis is that you instead of
look at the square of the one on is the
Distilled of you phenomenal but it
anyway so so this you know this would be
the sway of the one log would look like
this and now put people into testing is
that maybe we we relax the constraint
that the one arm is small and instead
just enforce that so what you want to
minimize so you have to constrain that
instead of saying this here is a small
assassin root is less than K now because
they squared the 10 I'm saying this is
system k you say that this year is less
okay so you know you remove that you
know you put the x value signs outside
which you know makes things only smaller
so this is still satisfied by sparse by
sparse vectors and you know now we can
solve this efficiently you know because
it's a convex constraint on these on
these on these numbers and efficiently
checkable context one strange uneasily
paseo resolutions yeah unfortunately
this for this problem with fails also
case quite dramatically and the reason
is some other nice reason you can choose
d to be an actual distribution and make
this sale in just use d to be the
uniform distribution
over the Sierra and all over that is it
we should have said here that is there
to warn the purchase year the this it'll
be in uniform distribution over there to
one of the subspace so now you know this
would actually be this would be an extra
distribution but what if you compute
that if you know if you was a random
subspace then as I guess hear what I'm
in uniform ya hear what I'm in uniform
you know even uniform just over these e
minus 1 vectors then it turns out that
you know in this case these these
expected these expectations will be a
little think again for the denture is
it's in over final time there's a Hootie
or just be but you know in a case you
can now look at look at this um you know
this this would always be the sub year
would obviously know if your
distribution was justice uniformity
which over the world would be less than
n over it's a now 18 and it means said
you know unless unless k is smaller than
a no kanata nobody you you know this
distribution looks like it's a
distribution of us pass vectors with
respect to to this constraint and then
so let's bet so this basically sort of
SS as much of a problem is here now what
you prefer you can do instead which
which turns out to work better is you
know the use appropriate degree for
point over here and write it before
point or maybe if you want to enforce
paucity would be
you know it happens at the constraint X
form of X you know it's k times 1 over
root K to the 4 which is ok squared okay
see at the constrain that the form of x
to the 4 which is a degree four-point-oh
meal is at least 1 over K and so this is
this would this is a vex fight by case
basis vectors and assist you see was
just a complication and he turns out
that you know if you enforce the
condition X this is equal to 1 over K
then it turns out the deceiver
distribution will be concentrated on the
vector V and just it means that you can
basically read off the vector V just
from the from the debris to moments but
you need to enforce this position about
the decree for me and the proof that the
dis condition is you know recovers the
response factor is
this is I guess I don't have to write
something it's a very natural so what
you do is you just proved that so if you
solve this it would solve this problem
you know exactly know exactly in the you
know without sir distributions just if
you you just proved that the vector that
is larger love lettuce this is larger
for norm in the subspace and the unit
vector that is larger phone home in the
subspace if you're going to prove that
this has to be has to be close to the
space vector V and it did I thought you
can prove it in a way that it is very
explicit explicit in a sense that you
know the proof uses only you know the
squares are negative and you know you
know the kind of inequalities are using
the proof only use in squares are
negative and now you know you notice
that that these properties are also
satisfied advisor distributions and that
means that you know a series of
illusions capture this proof and
therefore in c division series mutant
has to be concentrated on around the
vector that's what
I want to say with this program